a few days ago CS go content creator
Sparkles did a interesting albeit
slightly controversial interview with
two Infamous hackers in it they explain
how they do it the types of cheats
becoming available nowadays and what
their plans are to keep the party going
and Counter-Strike two but admits to all
that they shed some light on what I
think is the most important question of
all why do cheaters cheat
[Music]
all right I've said it a thousand times
and I'll probably say it a thousand more
cheaters suck on top of obviously being
annoying a waste of time and honestly
speaking pathetic cheaters can have a
lasting psychological effect on their
victims for example the other night I
was playing an unranked short match with
a couple of friends when the enemy
team's top Fragger who had been [__]
on us all match hit seven one digs in a
row an ace followed by two more in the
next round the guy with sauces now was
he cheating is he just better than me
why was his account private these are
the questions I find myself asking far
too often and I'm sure many of you can
relate as well but unless a player gets
banned off of your report which in my
experience doesn't happen too often
you'll probably never find out now if
scenarios like this happen enough
eventually you're going to start second
guessing every game and for as long as
I've been playing Counter-Strike
cheaters have gotten in the way of
having this competitive Integrity far
too often however a few weeks ago we
released a video discussing cs2's
improved anti-cheat and how it was
shaping up to be the answer we were all
waiting for whether they call it vac
live vacnet or vac 2.0 this updated
anti-cheat seemed like a beast because
from what we saw it seemingly had the
power to ban players the moment they're
reported and although we don't know
exactly how it works it does seem to be
a lot more complex incorporating things
like AI learning on top of the existing
foundations vac already has the point is
things were looking good Volvo's working
hard to solving what many consider to be
the biggest issue plaguing the franchise
however just a few days ago our pal
Sparkles sat down with two Infamous
Counter-Strike hackers to talk about not
just the current state of cheating but
what cheaters are already pulling off in
the CS2 Limited Test and folks as ready
as I was to emote on the gravestones of
these [__] Sparkles unraveled
the sobering truth that we aren't in the
clear just yet in fact the war on
Cheaters might have just started to
start off the two hackers wonder and
Bones spoke about the current state of
cheating in Counter-Strike GO and
honestly it was pretty surprising I was
not aware of the different types of
cheats that are currently available I
mean I remember the Glory Days of speed
hackers back in 1.6 but these days there
are a lot more options than just walls
and Aimbot one of the most surprising
cheats that I didn't know still existed
was anti-aim it Alters the position of
your hitbox so that it's slightly skewed
from your player model so that when
players aim at your head they actually
miss now one of the hackers does explain
that anti-aim used to be a lot more
broken but valve actually did something
to fix it during operation Riptide it's
this cat and mouse game between hackers
and valve that is at the heart of the
current issue in the interview it's
explained that every time valve fixes
something or discovers a new cheating
software it exposes something else which
results in new cheats hitting the market
the question is what about
Counter-Strike 2. surely the future is
brighter than what we've already been
through right well unfortunately it
seems to be the same old story although
it was just an offline build of dust 2
bones was able to show off what hackers
have been cooking up already if we go
and GitHub right now there's free cheats
you'll go on YouTube right now there's
free cheats cheats are going to be a lot
a lot more advanced when they come out I
have some new features here for example
box ESP is only working on enemies right
now it even works with like Health ESP
and stuff you know and that's pretty
simple you know we made it like about
one week now why is this scary well once
upon a time finding cheats in CS go
actually wasn't that easy but as bones
explains you can now find literal
tutorials on how to make them on YouTube
it was really hard to make cheats I know
everyone can can do so you know if you
look on YouTube how to make a CS Go
cheat there's whole tutorials for the
Counter-Strike cheat for 30 days costs
300 doubles three euros a month that's
how cheap it is to cheat so yes the new
vac does seem very powerful I mean even
bones and wonder are impressed by it but
Sparkles was also sent a document that
shows how variations of old exploits are
already being found in CS2 Evac life
doesn't come out strong it might be too
difficult for valve to catch up to what
these cheat developers can pull off
maybe it's already too late what is good
is that at least now in the opinion of
the hackers themselves valve is actually
doing something to solve the issue it
seems like now they are carrying because
of those two but on Source One they
didn't even care they are I don't know
you know I'm not working there what they
are doing now aside from all the things
we learned about the current state of
cheating was a little nugget of insight
into what I find more interesting why do
cheaters cheat in the first place I
understand why people like to cheat in
single player games hell they used to be
a ubiquitous feature put in by the
developers themselves I could even
understand why people cheat in pro games
or develop them for that matter I don't
think it's right but when there's money
involved at least the incentive is clear
but why cheat in this current ERA of
Competitive Gaming you know in regular
matchmaking what's the game we'll go you
into cheating a couple years later I
would say it was first of other Cheetos
same thing with wonder what most people
started cheating because of other
Cheetos now I think I speak for everyone
when I say [__] off I cheat because of
other cheaters is a ridiculous excuse
that being said I do think it gives us
some context into the motivations of
some of these people I know some people
cheat because they just simply don't
care they think it's funny or they want
to feel like a god so they download
cheats go wild get banned then move on
okay he doesn't give up [__] anymore
dude but for many of these serial
cheaters out there I don't think it's
that simple now I'm no psychologist here
but I don't think it's crazy to link
cheating in video games to issues
relating to emotional intelligence I
mean in the interview bones highlights
the three tiers of cheating and the
terminology that the community uses
legit semi-rage and rage it's very
curious that they call it rage but it
kind of makes sense you're getting [__]
on you get frustrated so you turn on all
of your hacks and go crazy usually to
get a reaction sure you were always
cheating but now you can't even control
yourself to hide it suddenly the guy who
had your number all game can't even get
a shot in now he's the one raging now
you finally get to win sounds a lot like
a lack of maturity to me finding out the
motivations for why people cheat will
always be interesting and judging from
the comments on Sparkle's video I'm sure
you guys have opinions of your own but
the real takeaway from this interview is
that the issue itself is not going away
anytime soon in the meantime all valve
can really do is fix the holes in the
game reverse engineer the cheats they do
find and develop back until it does both
for them and all we can do is hope to
God it actually works
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock